let's determine the moment of inertia of
a big wheel here we have a big wheel and
on the side it's it's attached here at
the center and there's a string going
around here and on that string is a
little mass hanging and disk here has
radius R and we now want to know in a
little experiment what what the moment
of inertia is of this disk and what we
have to do is we have to drop this mass
to the ground and we need to measure
what height is here and we need to
measure how long it takes to to drop so
we need to measure T so how we're gonna
go about that
well the moment of inertia that probably
has something to do with the torque of
this wheel so we have to start doing a
torque analysis so torque about the
center of mass equals moment of inertia
about the center of mass times the
angular acceleration and we need to
recall that the torque is the product of
the radius times the perpendicular force
so we're going to have R here and then
the force that's that's acting on this
wheel here is actually this tension
force here so we we're going to have our
T here and now we need to look at how
how things actually moving with respect
to a coordinate system so if I pull or
if I let this mass drop so the disk was
going to spin clockwise so we're going
to have theta hat going this way and if
theta hat is going clockwise my K hat
vector is going to go into the board and
if K hats gonna go there well then and
it's rotating clockwise the angular
acceleration
is gonna go in the K hat direction and
if that is the case then our torque is
gonna follow suit
so torque also goes into the into the
board and so that means here we're going
to deal with K hat direction and we're
gonna have ICM and then alpha Z in the K
hat direction okay so we can solve this
for I RT / z ok well that's pretty good
but we have two unknowns in here the T
and the alpha Z and we can use some
other concepts to actually get
information on those the T as you can
guess already plays a role here in this
massless string so we can do a quick
Freebody diagram and an F equals MA
analysis to get to get to that tension
force so we have our little mass M here
gravity is acting on it and we have this
tension force here and we're going to
put J hat down so we're going to get mg
minus T equals M a it's only gonna go
you know in the y y direction so we can
just leave it here do this we can solve
this for T and then we have G minus a
okay good so we have that now about the
angular acceleration and whenever
there's a string going around a disc
then we of course have a constraint
condition because the linear
acceleration of this little math going
down is related to the radius of the
disc times the angular acceleration so
we can solve this for alpha
and then we have a over are so let's put
that in here are then we have M G minus
a over a and then we get another R here
and we can write that it's a little bit
more compact M R squared G over a minus
1 good so now we have one last hurdle
namely that a here that a we can't
measure I said in the beginning we want
to make an experiment actually we need
that experiment because we can't we
can't otherwise get through this a so
what we need is a relation that that
connects what we can measure which is
the time it falls down this height here
to the acceleration of this block and of
course that comes from one-dimensional
kinematics and we know that H equals
one-half a T squared so we can solve
that for a to H over T squared and now
we can stick that in here and we have M
R squared and G T squared over 2 H minus
1 and let's just write this here again
and that is our final solution so now we
have only measurable quantities here the
T we can measure we just need a
stopwatch and the H we can imagine as
well and this actually already resembles
if you know the theoretical this already
resembles the theoretical solution which
of course is
for a disc 1/2 R squared so that's what
one expects for a disc and you see that
you know we're very close so this term
here is probably something like 1.5 or
should better come out to be 1.5 because
if we subtract 1 we get to that half
here and you can use it to in vitro in
return you can also use it to predict
the time it takes to fall down if you
know what the height is or or vice versa